let's do a couple of more of these
exponential decay problems because a lot
of this really is just practice and
being very comfortable with the general
formula and i'll write it again where
the amount of the element that's
decaying that we have at any period in
time is equal to the amount that we
started with
times e to the minus kt
where the k value is specific to any
certain element with a certain half-life
and sometimes they don't even give you
the half-life so let's let's try
interesting situation let's say that i
have a
element let's let me just give you a
formula
let's say that i have some magic element
here
where its
formula is its k value i give to you k
is equal to minus
let me think of a
excuse me i just had a lot of walnuts so
my throat is dry
let's say that k is equal to well k
we're putting a minus from r so i'll say
the k value is a positive
0.05 so its exponential decay formula
would be the amount that you start off
with times e to the minus .05
t
my question to you is
given this
what is the half-life of the compound
that we're talking about what is
the half-life
so to figure that out we need to figure
out what t-value can we put here so that
if we start off with whatever value here
we end up with half of that value there
so let's do that
so we're starting off with
n sub 0 this is just some value our
initial starting point we could put 100
there actually let's do that just to
keep things
just to keep things less abstract so
let's say we start with a hundred i'm
just picking a hundred out of air i
could have left it abstract with n let's
say i'm starting with a hundred
i take 100 times e to the minus .05
times t
t is whatever our half-life so after our
half-life we're going to have half of
this stuff left so this should be equal
to
50.
we just solve for t divide both sides by
100 you get e to the minus 0.05
t is equal to one half
take the natural log of both sides of
this
natural log of this
the natural log of that
and then you get the natural log of e to
anything i've said it before is just the
anything so it is
minus .05
t
is equal to the natural log of one half
and then you get t is equal to the
natural log of one half
divided by
minus .05
so let's figure out what that is
so if we have 0.5
the natural log and actually someone
just made a comment and i might as well
do that i could just put this minus up
here i can make this a plus and this a
minus if i just multiply the numerator
and the denominator by negative 1
and if i want to just to make the
calculator math a little easier if you
put a minus in front of a natural log or
any logarithm that's the same thing as
the log of the inverse
of 2 over 0.05 makes the calculator math
a little bit easier
same thing so if i do 2
natural log
divided by
0.05
it is equal to 13.86
13.86
so when t is equal to
t is equal to 13.86
and i'm assuming that we're dealing with
time in years that tends to be the
convention although sometimes it could
be something else and you'd always have
to convert to years but assuming that
this original formula where they gave
this key this k value of 0.05 that was
with the assumption that t is in years
then i've just solved its half-life i've
just solved that after 13.86
years
you can expect to have half of the
substance left we started with 100 we
ended up with 50. i could have started
with x and ended up with x over 2.
let's do one more of these problems just
so that we're really comfortable with
the formula
let's say that
i have
something with a half-life
half-life
of
i don't know let's say i have it as one
month
half-life of one month and
after
let's say that i
let's say that i'm well let me just just
for the sake of time let me make it a
little bit simpler let's say i just have
i have my k value is equal to i mean you
can go from half life to a k value we
did that in the previous video let's say
my k value is equal to 0.001
so my general formula
is the amount of product i have is equal
to the amount that i started with times
e to the minus .001
times t
and i gave you this if you had to figure
it out from half-life i did that in the
previous video with carbon 14 but let's
say this is the formula and let's say
that after
after
i don't know let's say after
after 1 000 years
i have
i have 500 grams of whatever element is
described the decay formula for whatever
element is described by this formula how
much did i start off with
so how much did i start off with so i'm
essentially i need to figure out n sub
zero right i'm saying that after five
thousand after a thousand years so n of
a thousand
which is equal to n sub naught times e
to the minus point zero zero one
times 1000
right that's the n of a thousand that's
the thousand and i'm saying that that's
equal to 500 grams
that equals 500 grams
so i just have to solve for n sub naught
so what's the e value so if i have point
zero zero zero one
times one thousand so this is n sub
naught
this is one thousandth of a thousand so
times e to the minus 1 is equal to 500
grams
or i could multiply both sides by e and
i have n sub naught is equal to 500 e
which is about 2.71 so let's 500
times
2.71 i don't actually have e on this
calculator at least i don't see it
it's equal to 13 55 grams so it's equal
to 1
355 grams or
1.355 kilograms
that's what i started with
355. so hopefully you see now i mean we
i think we've approached this pretty
much almost any direction that that that
a chemistry test or teacher could throw
the problem at at you
but you really just need to
remember this formula and this applies
to a lot of things later you'll learn
you know when you do compound interest
and finance the k will just be a
positive value but it's essentially the
same formula and there's a lot of things
that that this formula actually
describes well beyond just radioactive
decay but the simple idea is use the
information they give you to solve for
as many of these constants as you can
and then whatever they're asking for
solve for what's ever left over and
hopefully i've i've given you enough
examples of that but let me know i'm
happy to do more